Come on, kid.
The best thing about being a veterinary technician,...
...the thing that I love the most, is to be able to help animals.
To see them come in very sick, and then a few days later, they're going home.
And they're happy and the tails are wagging or they're meowing.
It's a wonderful feeling.
It really helps mend your heart.
On a daily basis, a veterinary technician does whatever is asked of him or her.
We tend to do a lot of restraint, holding animals and such.
We do do IV catheters.
We take blood from the animals and we often run the blood tests on the animals.
We do help to prep for surgeries, clipping and scrubbing and such.
We clean up after the animal, whatever needs to be cleaned up.
If we have time, we like to play with the animals...
...just to help have them be more comfortable in the hospital.